Ancient Egyptians believed the burial tomb
should contain everything needed for the afterlife,
so Kings were buried with gold, food, beer,
weapons, even pets!
But what about Ladies of the Court?
Where they at, tho?
One of the most famous Pharaohs of Egypt was
(and is) King Tut. But Tutankhamun's mother,
Nefertiti is a far more intriguing political
and cultural figure to Egyptologists. She
is legendary for her beauty, but also because
she, and her husband Akhenaten, turned Egypt
toward the cult of Aten the Sun God and away
from polytheism.
Nefertiti died before Tut, and no one knew
where she was buried (though they've been
looking for decades) and technology may have
finally revealed Nefertiti was hiding in plain
sight this whole time!
In a paper titled "The Burial of Nefertiti?"
Lead researcher Nicholas Reeves writes that
he believes Nefertiti is buried IN TUT'S TOMB.
Or more accurately, Tut was buried in Nefertiti's.
He believes there is a secret chamber behind
an elaborately painted wall in Tut's burial
chamber which houses the legendary Queen.
Tut's tomb is highly trafficked by tourists,
so to protect the original from human destruction,
a Spanish company took high-resolution photos
of the hieroglyphs and paintings and created
a reconstruction. Looking at those photos,
Reeves discovered fissures in the wall which
might hide secret doors. Obviously, they couldn't
go in and break down the walls, so instead,
the Egyptian Ministry of Antiquities scanned
the room with infrared thermography. Essentially,
scientists and engineers measured the surface
temperatures of the walls with infrared cameras;
two sections of the walls were cooler, meaning
there is space behind them!
Reeves believes one is a storeroom, and the
other -- NEFERTITI'S LOST BURIAL CHAMBER.
More research is needed before they can determine
if Nefertiti's Tomb is back there, or if they'll
cut into the wall to find her, but wow. This
could be huge. I love the idea that technology
is making archaeologists drool. In a "Scan
Pyramids" joint effort by Cairo University,
the University of Laval in Quebec and Nagoya
University in Japan, researchers pointed these
infrared thermography scanners at the Great
Pyramid at Giza; and after only two weeks
may have found ANOTHER undiscovered tomb!
While normally, variation in external stone
temperatures are only about point-1 to point-5
degrees, in one area the stones were SIX degrees
different. The researchers think they can
use lasers, drones and infrared scanners to
get a picture of the internal structure of
the pyramid without drilling and destroying
part of the historical building.
Advances in technology help archaeologists
gather information about ancient and fragile
artifacts without destructively manipulating
them by cutting them open or moving ancient
bones. The lasers they mention are probably
LIDAR -- or Light Detection and Ranging tech.
Using laserlight, archaeologists can get super-accurate
measurements of historical sites, which let
them create 3-D models. These computer models
can reveal details about construction, building
techniques, especially sensitive bits, or
areas for further exploration.
Drones and robots can also help get scans
or images from hard-to-reach places; back
in the 90s, a tiny crawling robot was sent
into a tiny, undisturbed burial chamber in
the Great Pyramid.
Even satellites are put to work in the hunt
for our history. 400 miles (644km) above the
Nile's shores, infrared satellite pictures
revealed 17 buried pyramids, 3,000 settlements,
and 1,000 tombs across Egypt. This took many
hundreds of hours of trial and error, but
newer techniques are looking at AI systems
to find these settlements…
Though there's no substitute for getting in
there with a brush, magnifying glass and phalanges;
archaeologists are finding technology to be
a powerful ally. I love this stuff.
If you have something you love, like Egyptology,
you could go to Domain.com and grab a website
to share your love with the world. Egypt.News
is available, so is EffYeahEgypt.pizza, or
Egypt.Expert or KingTut.Ninja. Whatever you
want!
No domain will help you tell your story like
a dot net or dot com and since you watch us
you can get 15 percent off domains and web
hosting if you use the offer code DNews!
What's your favorite story from world history?
King Tut?
The sacking of Carthage by Rome?
The Huns in China?
How about the history of ancient alcohol?
We've got that last one for you…
some scientists made wine using this ancient
recipe and they tasted it…
Want to know what it tasted like?
Watch this oldie but a goodie!